the US military has launched a new
school to train American armed forces in
how to counter the emerging threat of
drones or what it calls unmanned
aircraft systems or uas the first
Academy of its kind The Joint counter
small unmanned aircraft systems
University or jcu will train about 1,000
troops a year Warfare is changing very
fast this threat right here this current
threat with respect to uas it is it's
the pace of your phone changing
this footage is from a Ukrainian drone
attack carried out against Russian
forces and this video is from a Hamas
drone attack in November carried out
against Israeli forces in
Gaza the proliferation of small cheap
commercially available drones is
transforming Modern Warfare and this has
not been lost on The
Pentagon Colonel mosf SAA is the
director of the jcu the pace of the need
is out growing capacity right now so
we're trying to train as many people as
possible and trying to grow as fast as
possible to to uh fit that need today
students at Fort Sill are training on
weapon systems to counter small unmanned
aircraft all right so what we have in
front of us here is what's known as the
smart shooter uh the what the name
implies is what it does all right so the
smart shooter itself is a smart optic
that is placed onto the M4 weapon system
uh to allow the soldier a better
opportunity to engage small uas threats
that are very
close Smart shooter training does
involve drones but students don't shoot
directly at
them instead they shoot at balloons
dangling below the drones on a string
the jcu said balloons are more cost
effective and thanks to the high winds
in Oklahoma a harder Target to
hit nice so the soldier replaces weapon
into to operational way they do for any
other uh situation from that point there
you would look through the optic which
would acquire to Target for you at which
case the soldier would pull the trigger
and the rest of it is done by the weapon
system nice the students are also
learning how to use another handheld
system the Drone Buster whereas the
smart shooter
utilizes U the 556 round this is known
as an electronic attack system so the
soldiers taking this here and they're
pointed in a general direction of the
Target that they see and then a soldier
replac it in operation utilize various
gemming means to uh interdict that
Target
the jcu says these weapon systems and
others like them are already in the
hands of US forces around the world it's
not just the Air Force anymore that is
using unmanned aerial vehicles or drones
it is also ground forces that every
Echelon have different types of drones
that provide them with intelligence
surveillance and reconnaissance as well
as targeting and sometimes strike
capabilities before the jcu was created
soldiers who trained on anti-drone
weapon systems did So within their own
branches The Joint counter uas
University the intent here is to
standardize and centralize the training
so that we can all have interoperability
as we work together and integrate the
system successfully with respect to the
threat training typically lasts between
1 to 3 weeks students are selected by
their commanders but some volunteer to
attend as far as branches of military
coming through the jcu we are seeing
service members from all branches we
also train federal agencies as well as
Allied and partner nations in the Years
following the September 11th attacks the
US deployed large sophisticated
expensive drones for surveillance and
Strikes in Iraq and Afghanistan The
First Time commercial drones were used
in a conflict was in Iraq when Isis
deployed the technology in the battle
for mosul Isis began to modify small
quadcopters and use them to attack Iraqi
and US forces and this presented an
unprecedented challenge in recent years
civilian drones modified with explosives
have become a growing Menace for troops
in Syria Gaza and Ukraine drones are
fundamentally changing the way that
militaries fight they are allowing
different states to perform missions
that previously were too expensive
having an Air Force on the cheap for
example many of the small drones being
used in combat today in Ukraine come
from one Chinese company DJI DGI drones
aren't made to fire weapons but they can
be easily modified to carry a grenade or
other small explos
last year DGI said it would stop selling
its drones to Ukraine and Russia because
the technology was not intended to be
used for military activities in Ukraine
you've seen just an explosion of
commercial and do-it-yourself drones on
a level that has never been seen before
both parties are employing them at all
echelons the ukrainians were the first
movers here and you've seen them move
into firstperson view drones the small
fast uh quadcopters that are essentially
kamakazi and crash into their target
students at Fort Sill are also training
for an emerging threat drone swarms the
term refers to a network of multiple
unmanned aerial flying platforms
integrated together by a single system
we have the ability to replicate uh
drone swarms here and this is very
important because as a student you'll
have a a realistic appraisal of the
difficulties that these different
platforms present but also you'll have
an understanding of the capabilities of
what you're utilizing to neutralize that
threat
given how rapidly drone technology is
developing the Pentagon believes there's
no single weapon system that can be
relied upon you're really in a cost
competition because so many of the
drones are very cheap today that you
don't want to be firing something that
is much more expensive to intercept and
Destroy them there is no Silver Bullet
when it comes to counter uas so there is
no one system that is most effective
commanders have to determine based off
of planning factors which system is best
to be utilized against the threat and so
what we want to do is make sure we use a
layered approach using multiple systems
planning against that and different
environments don't look for one way out
you want to create multiple dilemas
which then makes it difficult for the
adversary to develop means to defeat
what you're putting
together